[Música]
con sus 2500 castillos el valle del
loira es la cuna del renacimiento
francés un patrimonio de inestimable
riqueza que requiere un mantenimiento
constante con tecnología de punta
investigación histórica y materiales de
época los artistas y artesanos del
patrimonio francés
innovan para devolver a estas joyas del
pasado su estado original
janet un escultor
se reúne con el propietario del sat dice
debes restaurar las ventanas
abuhardilladas de la fachada
renacentista
[Música]
las dos guardias tienen un estilo
similar por lo que deberíamos encontrar
el mismo tipo de estructura hay dos
ángeles en lugar de dos bestias el
escudo en el centro tienen exactamente
las mismas dimensiones y de hecho son
similares en términos decorativos el
castillo está suntuosamente decorado sus
propietarios renacentistas eran ricos y
realizaron una obra maravillosa pero
necesita mucha restauración sobre todo
porque utilizaron toda una piedra caliza
local que es mucho más escamosa que
otras calizas así que cuando se mira lo
que no se ha restaurado a menudo no
queda mucho antes de iniciar los
trabajos de restauración ya nec se
remite a una documentación precisa para
conservar la autenticidad histórica
este es el libro de la cnea
con los grabados fechados en 1699
con un hermoso dibujo de los estudios en
las butacas que estamos restaurando
este es el que tienes que copiar para la
buhardilla le enviaré una foto perfecto
o una fotocopia para la buhardilla a
restaurar en junio en su taller janet no
utiliza cinceles de albañilería para
esculpir la piedra sino cincel es de
madera como los escultores del
renacimiento utilizamos estos cinceles y
gubias de madera para la piedra porque
la piedra de la región es muy blanda el
follaje debe verse muy natural
tengo que hacer todo lo posible para
meterme en la mente del escultor
original adentrarse en la mente del
artista utilizando técnicas de época es
también el método de estos dos
especialistas en pintura mural ya han
acudido a valorar unos frescos del siglo
15 los dos grandes problemas son uno el
yeso descascarado como aquí debido a la
humedad que ha debilitado el yeso
pintado y dos estos pequeños agujeros
hechos por el hombre los cuales han
arruinado en la superficie general así
que tendremos que arreglarlo
esta figura de la capilla fue
reproducida de forma idéntica a 50
kilómetros de distancia en la sede de
muro del arte un conservatorio dedicado
a la investigación histórica del arte
mural
[Música]
aquí estoy dañando un fragmento de la
pintura tal y como podría dañarse de
forma natural para hacer algunas pruebas
de limpieza y consolidación de ella es
un edificio del siglo 18 tiene ciertas
patologías como las sales ascendentes y
la humedad en la unión y utilizando
copias de las pinturas y empleando las
técnicas de cada época podremos ver cómo
se generaron las patologías en la
pintura en unas semanas o meses para
tratar las patologías del fresco la
solución que aplicarán no es un producto
químico inventado en un laboratorio sino
una receta cercana al proceso original
de nuestras investigaciones nos han
demostrado que los mejores métodos son
los ancestrales un limitados escalón así
que investigamos estos métodos
ancestrales y los estudiamos y luego
hicimos algunas pruebas más y recreamos
una metodología
a pocos kilómetros se encuentra uno de
los castillos más bellos de francia
después de versalles el castillo de
chambord su construcción fue ordenada en
1519 por francisco primero y fue
terminada
veinte años más tarde durante la primera
parte del reinado de luis catorce
faroles fosos y escaleras aquí la
restauración es constante pero para que
perdure algunos estudian el origen de
los daños como kevin beck investigador
de la universidad de google
especializado en las patologías de la
caliza de toba
esta toba calcárea es definitivamente de
la época original es decir del siglo 16
es la piedra original del castillo de
chambord esta piedra ha sufrido una
considerable declamación perdiéndose
aquí una losa de dos o tres centímetros
de grosor
aquí estoy tomando una muestra de piedra
de la zona fisurada que luego analizar
en el laboratorio quiero ver si hay
contaminantes presentes en el interior
de la piedra que puedan explicar el
agrietamiento
regresamos al laboratorio donde las
preciosas muestras se trituran y muelen
y luego se analizan cuidadosamente la
piedra toba calcar ya posee las
cualidades estéticas requeridas en el
renacimiento ya que es blanca muy ligera
y fácil de tallar - pero también es muy
porosa y puede ser fácilmente alterado
por su entorno por eso es importante
vigilarla y realizar un mantenimiento
regular para aumentar su durabilidad
más allá de las patologías de la piedra
otros científicos se especializan en el
examen en 3-d de obras de arte y
mampostería valiosa tecnología para la
restauración de edificios históricos
[Música]
proporciona a los restauradores datos de
altísima calidad lo que les permite ser
muy precisos durante los trabajos de
restauración ya sea de antemano en
cuanto al conocimiento del objeto o más
tarde en el proceso cuando están
tratando los materiales y restaurando
los
la alta tecnología al servicio del
conocimiento
entre la investigación histórica los
conocimientos técnicos y las
innovaciones tecnológicas el patrimonio
del valle del loira sigue teniendo un
futuro brillante
[Música]